I think one o'clock we'll start on work
session
okay we're talking about timing
and having uh
uh agencies back in for further budget
review
just off the top of your head
uh as a hip shot where are we for
agencies where there's Comfort level or
there's not Comfort level
and I had and of course I haven't got
any guidance yet about what what are we
going to do because we're off
with the with the governor's budget
an accrual of about 90 million dollars
something like that
we maybe we get to scheduling after I do
have this packet that I handed out here
today and this will what I've done is
tried to compile everything that the
agencies have asked for everything in
House Bill 2 all of our bills so maybe
once we see these specific subject
matters that we still have to get
through that may decide how much time we
need with who okay uh oh this is both
this is all divisions so that yet so I
gave I gave out an index that has uh all
of the sections for the entirety of
house bill 2. so that's the stapled uh
landscape uh right oriented document so
that's really just a reference document
for for anyone who just wants to find a
section quick uh as far as division two
Focus work there's another packet here
with a binder clip on it
so this one here just has house division
two sections so
I can walk us through real briefly I
don't want to dive into every subject
matter but at least uh this is kind of a
catch-all of everything we've identified
is going to be referred to division two
so the first two things are are very
easy house bill one so in the back of
house bill one we have some what we
usually refer to as boilerplate language
so Lottery Commission has authority to
buy uh their ticket Supply in the back
of Hospital one it's been there for
decades really just a rubber stamp okay
to continue that
and then positions abolish is always in
the back of house bill one any old
positions that the agencies don't need
any longer they just get wiped out so
those two sections
um
at some point we'll do an affirmative
vote in the committee just to be okay
with that we haven't heard anything from
the agencies that need any changes to
those so you're probably good to go with
those
jumping into house bill too we've got a
lot of House Bill too this year compared
to the last couple so I'll go through
them very quickly uh we talked about
dual and concurrent enrollment the
governor did provide some funding and
House Bill 2 relative to that as well as
the program change to that which was
allowing for more courses to be offered
per student we also heard from the
community college system that they put
forth a section in House Bill 2 uh
changing the retirement system
eligibility for employees hired after
January 1st 2024.
uh we heard about the Appropriations for
UNH the interoperability lab as well as
the Whittemore Center
both of those Appropriations and I tried
to indicate on here
there's some Appropriations that are in
24 some in 25 and then there's also many
appropriations of using fiscal 23 what
we call them Surplus dollars if you will
so those would be a hit to the general
fund before this current fiscal year
ends
yeah around the Whittemore Center the
funds of 2023 which is now
um clearly they're not going to be
starting construction anytime soon so
um why would it need to be in 2023 as
opposed to could we put it in 2024 or I
know you know UNH has said this will
help them leverage many of millions of
dollars to get to the final the the
um total amount so it was putting it
into 2023 a way of helping them or
what's it's a way of eating up uh
Surplus I couldn't think of the word
yeah it does it does include non-lapsing
language so it'll be available for them
when they are ready to spend it but
under current law uh at the end of every
biennium any unexpended general funds
would go to the rainy day fund so this
is essentially using the general funds
available in the state budget in 23
before the close of the biennium Mary
are they General funds or are they
education trust funds uh General funds
so I do have uh Appropriations later on
on this list and I did indicate which
ones are ETF thank you thank you
so I'm gonna fly through these uh
there's a repeal of the advanced
manufacturing education advisory Council
there's also changes to the higher
education trust fund the scholarship
trust fund the unique program and for
those who have been on this committee
before there's been proposals in the
past relative to the regenerative
manufacturing debt relief program the
governor's House Bill 2 introduced
includes an expansion of that program
which is administered by the business
Finance Authority with a revenue stream
from the uh unique uh the uh higher
education trust fund so there's quite a
few pages in House Bill 2 relative to
this and we'll hear from
possibly someone from treasury business
Finance Authority we should probably
invite in as well as perhaps someone
from the governor's office to explain uh
the basis for it as well as uh you'll
probably hear from University system on
this one as well
the next set there's a few uh
Appropriations as well as a position
established and a new uh
program relative to computer science and
stem administered by the departions with
them and and learn more and you'll see
there's about a five million
appropriation into this computer science
program that's non-lapsing that's a
charge against fiscal 23 funds
we did hear from the Department of
Safety that the governor's house bill to
included a million dollars for the body
Cam and dashboard camera fund and that
again is a charge to fiscal 23.
um there's in-house Bill 2 it
establishes a commission relative to New
Hampshire Civics and appropriates two
million dollars for the development of a
textbook a Civics text textbook again A
charged to 23 funds
uh 250 000 appropriated to the
Department of Education relative to the
teacher of the year program and that's
that's existed for a while
yeah I think there is some uh private
funds that do come in this would be a
significant increase I believe I'd have
to double check what the historical
funding level has been we heard from the
Department of Safety relative to the
northern border Alliance program there's
a dedicated Fund in house bill to
establish as well as an appropriation of
about 100 1.4 million dollars
Department of Transportation has quite a
few
statutory changes that vary across a few
subject matters uh that I I don't
necessarily believe have a super direct
budgetary impact but we probably would
want to invite them in to to walk us
through these we'll probably have other
items to discuss with them anyways I
will pause there and just say I don't
know what the overall plan is there's
been years where the division has worked
through these sections with the agencies
there's been years where for instance
these dot sections would go down to
Public Works and highways and they would
decide what to do with them since they
do have some policy involved I don't
know what the chairs in mind with that
chair Weiler so
at the very least they will eventually
come back here for a final up or down or
whatever you want to do but I don't know
if the policy committees are going to
get involved with any of these
well when we had
the last time the governor gave us a
really big list of kind of
things that nobody really ever asked for
but we're in hb2 we kind of went through
it and just eliminated them those that
we thought were unnecessary and then we
um had that much more money to use for
something else
so I don't know if that's something we
want to think about here
and certainly just like any Bill uh all
of these sections are subject to
Amendment deletion you know whatever
um
and it'll be up to the committee how you
want to handle
so I'm going to just pick on one for
instance the new ham the UNH
interoperability lab appropriation
I always like it I think I always think
it's neat and tidy when the committee
will vote to yes we vote to keep that in
you know have an affirmative vote to
keep that in uh if
you don't have a vote to delete it and
you don't have a positive vote to to
keep it in I don't know maybe the almost
like a we established the rule I guess
how we're going to handle a section like
that say we have a tie vote and just for
whatever reason we'll committee okay so
so we would go to full and I expect the
other divisions are going to try to work
through how to handle those situations
if we always have an odd number of of
members voting we it shouldn't be an
issue but I was thinking if we happen to
have a day and we end up with a three
three or a 4-4 tie what happens to that
section does it stay in the bill or does
it you know so that's I'm just tossing
that out there because normally it would
that would indicate it lost a tie but in
this particular case I think it
indicates it goes to the full function
it would remain in the in the bill
because it's in there as introduced
that's kind of what our thought was but
we just want to make sure that's clear
and known to everyone as we proceed Mary
are you comfortable with that
okay
you know like a leader and talk about
until
next week
so someone can I can get some if we're
gonna if we're gonna vote yeah that's
fine sure
so jumping down so I do have all the
page numbers the page numbers should
align to House Bill 2 the section
numbers will align
um as well the next section we heard
from the Department of Safety relative
to the auxiliary State Police Force so
there's a statute that limits that Force
to 16 uh folks 50 16 persons and this
removes that cap allowing the the forest
to be uh I guess within however many
positions they can fill at their
budgeted levels
we had heard from the Department of
Safety relative to changing the
statutory fee for the motor vehicle
records to be fee amounts set through
administrative rule so you'll see that
section 149 and then as well as the
ability for the Department to uh
provide driver records upon requests to
Federal entities within certain
parameters which was in line with what
they do for non-federal or
non-governmental agencies
um but those two things this is an
opportunity for them to raise their
rates
it's an opportunity for them to set the
fee in statute all right rules sorry I
guess the so um
recall whatever we were discussing
stayed with us but because there was a
potential of additional Revenue there
was a discussion about whether it needs
to go to Ways and Means so does that not
pertain here because it may be an
increase and that would be up to again
if the committee as a whole is going to
decide to parse out Pro uh sections for
the policy committees to review I will
say I think we had heard from the
Department that some of their budget is
built on the assumption that they would
be raising these fees through rules
during this biennium
next we had heard from the Department of
Safety relative to the fire marshal
doing the inspection of the residential
care and health facilities if you recall
they'd mentioned the governor's budget
removed positions at the Department of
Health and Human Services changed the
responsibility to safety but those
positions were not added at safety and
that was their top prioritized need was
to get those two general funded
positions and we'll get to that later
and uh this afternoon I've got a page
for that
uh Department of Safety had a position
established within the fire Mark or the
fire safety office this is a different
position to the inspectors
there's two reoccurring uh sections that
we've seen in the past relative
Department of Safety providing them the
authority to fill unfunded positions so
in the state budget each unique position
number is either funded or it's not
funded
this would give the department a safety
flexibility that if they had money in
their budget elsewhere they could fill
and fund one of those unfunded positions
but they still could stay with they'd
have to stay within their budgeted
amounts that would only be for two years
it's biennial yeah and same thing with
the ability to create a full-time
temporary positions
on the next page the continuation of the
Granite Shield program is an
appropriation of just over 1.2 million
dollars in each fiscal 24 and 25.
we had heard from the Department of
Safety that there would be some sections
in the house bill too relative to uh
emergency medical care providers
um
the suspension of RSA 99b this is the we
refer to them as the Weiler caps on
Highway funds the department had
requested that that statute be suspended
as essentially a belt and suspenders my
rough estimates are they are in
compliance and the suspension of this
law is not necessary but as we finalize
all our work I'll make sure that we
either are compliant or that suspension
is considered if you need it but I don't
think you're going to need that yeah
thank you Mr chair um just a quick
question I'm really not familiar with
that particular statue that they're
looking to suspending do you have a
15-20 second summary of what it says
essentially says of all the Gross Road
toll and motor vehicle Revenue collected
by the state certain amounts have to be
appropriated to Dot and certain amounts
cannot exceed non-dot agencies got it
thanks
next we had heard from Department of
Safety relative to the state and local
cyber security grant program is uh about
2.8 million dollars 2.9 over the
biennium appropriated for that purpose
and Department of Safety has a three and
a half million dollar appropriation of
fiscal 23 funds for the purchase of 52
state police cruisers so this year
Department of Safety did have quite a
few so I would expect we would want them
back to go into detail uh Steve Lavoy
and commissioner Quinn had gone through
these at high level when they were in
with us last week but I think diving a
little bit deeper now that we have House
Bill 2 text maybe appropriate at a
future a work session
then we get into mostly education from
here on out uh there's sections relative
to expanding the definition of an
eligible student for Education Freedom
accounts
uh and you'll also know that you know or
you're probably aware there's a couple
bills flying around including a couple
on uh this week's
um this Thursday's yeah this Thursday's
uh house floor there's there's a couple
of bills relative to EFA eligibility so
depending on what
um happens as a house position
you know it's probably all you don't
want to pass anything conflicting so we
just want to make sure we at least
capture whatever the the decision is and
don't have
um multiple pieces of legislation that
can flick pass
similarly there's a bill on the the
floor uh Thursday relative to the
education trust fund and allowable uses
also including uh allowing the
Department of Education to retain some
of it for administration and that is
also in house bill 2. so similarly
whatever the committee wants to do with
that from a policy position that bill
and House Bill 2 kind of do the same but
slightly different things so we'd want
to make sure we unify uh whatever the
policy is you want to move forward with
uh we've heard about the school building
Aid fund and this house bill 2 includes
a 75 million dollar transfer from the
education trust fund to the school
building Aid fund it's called but that
transfer would occur 30 June 2025
essentially allocating money for next
biennium it's spent in this budget but
it wouldn't actually be provided in aid
until 26 and 27 presumably
you've got to walk me through that one
one more time sure so uh so in in-house
Bill 2 yeah there's a transfer of 75
million dollars it hits fiscal 25 but
the transfer is set to occur on June 30
the last day of the biennium so it's
spent in this budget but it's really
because it is only there for the last
day of the biennium it's intended to be
expended next biennium so it's a charge
against this budget but kind of planned
on for probably a way to take a
excess what's the word again we lost it
sir yes it's a way to take Surplus and
put it in a future by any essentially
yep okay yeah that makes sense so it
essentially earmarks 75 million dollars
from this year's education this
biennium's education trust fund for
school building Aid payments for next
biennium but it does not make this
year's education uh building fund 75
million no there is some money in in
here relative to new projects for 24 and
25 but that 75 would be for the next
buying okay and this also the discussion
around this is whether or not
this is appropriate to take out of the
education trust fund which hmm
yeah this would be I think the third
budget in a row that we've started to
use education trust fund for school
building Aid okay
uh next there's a section relative to
court ordered payments Court I say court
ordered payments it should be court
order placement payments and special
education to also be used for the
education trust fund I have a schedule
for the education trust fund in this
pack and we'll I'll point out there's a
few new programs that are being charged
for that fund that are unusual so this
is the authority and law to to make that
permissible
currently it's General funds and this
would just make it so it's education
trust funds that's the only change here
right I think that legislation I may
have been a co-sponsor on and uh it's
it's basically a form of an unfunded
mandate where we you know require
certain things but we don't pay for it
so we need to fix that and we can get to
it when we get to more and we do have a
bill I think tomorrow on our slate for
tomorrow relative to episode of
treatments being included into what the
state's paying for yeah so that's the
bill I was talking about so this is not
that never mind this is just changing
the color of the money essentially of
what we're how we're paying yep
oh let's see where are we next is the uh
CTE the Career and Technical education
program so historically those funds
would be House Bill 25 capital budget
for the renovation or construction of CT
centers
uh the governor has proposed 12 and a
half million dollars for the Sugar Hill
River Valley Regional tech center uh to
come from the education trust fund so
there's nothing in the capital budget
for CT renovation it's all essentially
in the operating budget and there's
House Bill 2 language changing the
statute so this would essentially be an
ongoing uh operating budget expense no
longer capital
the next one two three four five six
seven or so sections rows on here are
all different components of the
governor's recommended changes to the
adequate education formula so we heard
from the Department last week Mark
walked us through the spreadsheet uh
there's there's a lot of options here
whatever the committee wants to do when
it comes to education funding we have a
couple of bills that I think we have
scheduled for work session tomorrow that
pass education in the house and have
been referred to us relative to changing
the education funding formula so
that's it's the biggest line item in the
budget and um It's usually the one of
the heavier lifts for division two
deciding where you want to go with Ed
funding
um
so jumping down page 68 section 177
there's a repeal of the third grade
reading Statewide uh Assessment program
data and my my suspicion is this is
relative to getting rid of the third
grade reading component of the ad Ed
funding that we touched upon earlier
there's a change in a chapter law that
was passed two years ago relative to
this state's ability to stay compliant
with maintenance of equity when it came
to federal funds there's a reference
added to include charter schools into
that determination so we might be able
to might be able to ask the department
the necessity for that
and then the last two things on here the
governor's proposed changing the Revenue
allocations for business profits and
business Enterprise tax
simplifying how those are determined but
it does shift more Revenue to the
general fund from the education trust
fund and I have a schedule showing that
later on
so this this document I'm going to keep
track as we go along in this far right
column the action so it could be we take
a vote to accept it it could be we take
a vote to delete it because you don't
agree with it or if there's an amendment
to alter it in any way I would have an
amendment number carried in here based
on something we've drafted and voted on
so I'm going to track all of our changes
to House Bill 2 on this and I'll try to
update this every time we meet you so
everyone knows where we're at and then
down below on the second page that's
open for anything a new section of House
Bill 2 if anything comes along that's
not relative to what's in the bill is
introduce something new that doesn't
have a corresponding section I would
list them down there
so that's where we are with House Bill
2. I know I went through that very
quickly and you know when you look at
the number of pages and and the the uh
the content that's behind them it's
probably gonna take a little bit longer
to work through them with the agencies
but that's essentially the long
Insurance just going out to the agencies
uh they uh House Bill 2 went out was
published last week and they should be
familiar with what is in there it was
not this document here that we're
walking through is online right now okay
so when when anyone does come in I'll
make sure they're we're all working from
the same okay same place would be
helpful
any questions with House Bill 2
beside I mean as far as as far as that
let me say any questions with Hospital 2
index here we just walked through
so the next page looks like this way
more numbers way more cells so this is
just I've compiled all of the agency's
requests that you heard uh their
prioritized needs any technical changes
that were brought forward there's a
couple things on here that actually uh
were brought to my attention after the
agency came in
but I listed them on here just so if we
have follow-up with the agencies it'll
it'll all be compiled
um I or I sorted them by agency so the
department of safety goes all the way
down until row 28 and you'll notice on
rows 27 and 28 there's some shading
there so I've shaded what we've
tentatively approved this was their uh
they had brought forward some technical
Corrections they needed so
um I'll shade any items that we approve
between uh now and when we get when
we're complete just so we can keep track
of that uh fishing game it had some
requests transportation
education
Lottery
um
ccsnh usnh and police standards which we
did the police standards one as well
but this is essentially changes that
would impact
pretty sure everything in here would
impact House Bill won so our operating
budget document so if any of these we
can that the committee supports I would
make the data entry changes into house
bill one
yeah yeah other you know just I just
gotta turn your mic and that's exactly
what I wanted to say uh I've been
watching these online and when you don't
key in on the mic and I notice you did
it also it doesn't come out and if you
might have something important to say
that's important everybody so if you
would thank you
the question is not the problem
so looking at this with the totals at
the bottom
uh there isn't there a grand tone no I
didn't I didn't total this up this is
over and above the governor's budget so
anything on here is the change to the
governor's budget so yeah these would
all be increases too
well since we're since our revenues are
less than the governors
these aren't going to happen unless we
want to do
knock something else out to replace it
with this
correct essentially so yeah so we'll
we'll probably put together a document
that's kind of higher level with the
general fund picture now that Ways and
Means has some revenues approved they
did come in less than the governor's uh
estimates so that will impact
um some of the
priorities the governor had as far as
how much money goes to the rainy day
fund or how much money is left over in
the education trust fund uh and that
that's up to the committee to decide
from a policy position how much you want
to spend and and whether you want to
stay within certain Revenue parameters
or have a certain amount go to the rainy
day fund there's a lot of big pieces I
would probably have to be established to
know if you and division two could
afford some of these things right okay
so but right now they're on in the wings
I would say it probably would require a
little bit of coordination across all
three divisions to know kind of where
you're at
but let me pick on Cahill I I just have
to notice on the top of the second page
uh
his proposals for
oh that's his back that that that's his
pointing to re retroactive okay yeah and
and
hang with me I'm hoping all of these
numbers are accurate so I tried to
reconcile so a lot of these bills when
we do the fiscal notes we do them based
on current law but I tried to update the
amounts here to be reflective of the
governor's budget so not so when you
when you look at these numbers it's
really how much would you have to add to
the governor's budget okay for school
building aid for instance not counting
that 75 million the operating budget
includes additional funds for our
project this would be the net above and
beyond that so they're a little bit if
you looked at the fiscal notes of these
bills they'd be more expensive than what
you see here because the governor
already covered some of it in in this
document
so so yeah I've got the bills on the
next page listed uh
we've got you know 10 or so bills that
we've already retained we've got 10 or
more so I think 10 for tomorrow that
we're also going to consider there's a
couple of bills that I I don't have a
fiscal analysis for and I'm probably not
going to have one what are you looking
at I'm sorry the second page of that
okay if you flip over where the bills
are listed
feel pretty confident with the ones that
we've retained as far as the estimates
to do with that down below where we've
got the pending which is the bills we
have scheduled for tomorrow
can I I just mention about
um House Bill 601 you've got a fiscal
um expectation there and in fact if that
were to be put into
our law or the authority given to the
Department of Ed that could not go into
effect until
um 2026 because right now we couldn't
even apply for it so I don't know if
it's appropriate what we're looking for
is the authorization it doesn't need to
be any money
for the adequacy or right so the impact
of the Ed funding amounts that wouldn't
kick in until 26. yes for some of the
nutrition areas of for the estate match
we do for meals and the department said
they would need a position so those
costs reflect
um more Administration that's not
relative to what would increase in the
adequacy formula the kind of a bigger
number we're expecting to see for the
Medicaid director that wouldn't hit and
change the adequacy until fiscal 26. so
you're right on that so these were just
other costs the department identified to
implement thank you
just a quick note while we are talking
about various bills I'm looking at hb129
hygiene product in schools
um I think that while I believe that
that bill you know
needs to address a you know unfunded
mandate mandate
I think we can probably Tinker with a
bill to significantly reduce the
reimbursement and still meet the actual
mandate uh you know expectations so
while we talk about certain things that
may or may not happen you know uh I
don't think it should be at this level
you know I want to see significantly
lower amounts but as long as we have a
mandate we gotta pay something
to defray those you know scores but I
would say it should be significantly
less than it is right now yeah and I
think along with that I think
in the bill is presented it had
retroactive payments and I think we
eliminate the original actor we can
figure the details out but and that's
something you can decide Mr chair how
you want to proceed if we get to you
know we've got all these bills if you
wanted to have a open dialogue or if
anyone wanted to come in with a separate
Amendment work I could work on an
amendment bring something in that does
any of these changes you're thinking
that's up to the committee and how you
want to proceed but any of those bills
and the spending ones especially which
is most of the ones we've retained
um we would have to draft a house bill
to Amendment right so
um
you know we can either do that as a
group or if any individual member wants
to work with me and do an amendment just
the question because you know I'm new to
all this we have a very limited amount
of time and it takes time to get to the
OLS I just want to stay that personally
I would feel that the best way to
approach these situations would be to
you know discuss as a committee whether
certain changes to a bill may be
appropriate or not without drafting a
full Amendment on a simple bills at
least like this and if we reach an
agreement in committee then we can just
draft the amendment we agreed to you
know and formally approve it rather than
prepare five different scenarios burden
owls burden Mickey
some bills may require that if they are
complex enough you need to see the
language but for really simple stuff
like that I'd appreciate you know more
relaxed process if it meets everybody
else's expectations
well we
we can decide what we want to do
so I think
I would like to move forward on that on
the hygiene products
take the original bill as offered
uh reduce the the annual to three
dollars instead of twelve dollars
uh
drop the retroactive payment
and take out girl and put in
menstruating person
is that everybody comfortable with that
one
okay actually you'd have to also take
out eight there is an age
um limit there I would suggest removing
the agent if you are staying
menstruating student or person or what
no that takes care of you you don't need
an aged definition
whatever yeah okay good point
I don't have the bill in front of me but
I don't know if we needed to to Define
in some way
the population that the department would
be paying the reimbursements on
would it be appropriate to say
menstruating person in the bill and then
tell the department for the purposes of
estimating the impact assume you know
all these students from this age you
know to get the ballpark impact I don't
know yeah I'd have to look at the bill I
don't know if it was a reimbursement so
that the local education agencies would
apply for reimbursement so maybe they
would say who their eligible students
are I don't know I think it was a
straight up payment based on the number
of
all right
because uh we're getting into the world
of transgenderism
well
we said we said
not necessarily appropriate language but
a girl who identifies as a boy will
menstruate but that individual
identifies as a boy so yeah you would
have
in that world it's a way to avoid all
that
that was I I'll talk to you offline
about that because that's kind of
there's part Legend there but there's
also a very sad story because of the
school shootings that led to that but
I'd be glad to talk to you about that
later
so the the bill does refer to a funding
request form that the department would
develop so I think the the districts
would complete that and provide it where
it does say the Department of Education
shall fund the local acquisition of
products at a rate of X dollars we
talked about three instead of 15 is
what's in the bill and then it says for
every enrolled female having passed her
12th birthday if we don't Define 12th
birthday I don't know
I don't know I think you have to Define
I think your language is right either
you're menstruating or you're not
doesn't matter your age and there are
girls who are menstruating at 10 now
sadly
and there are girls who menstruate later
and there is no I mean it's it's
reasonably straightforward for a school
to estimate how many of their students
will need this they know their students
better I don't think I you know want to
set this age or that age and again the
ages change you know
why have it Eric
you know when the uh the principle was
in there
and uh testified
he said that everything went fine until
this was mandated and the way that I
took what he had to say was that if you
eliminated the Mandate this entire
discussion is moved yep
so why not eliminate the Mandate the guy
running the show that's what he he wants
to do the the principal and I think the
other one was superintendent a
superintendent they both agreed
why are we going through all this just
to eliminate the Mandate because some
schools did not make it available
apparently that's their decision I was
on vacation that local control sorry
yeah
but I apparently there was a identified
need for the legislation so
rather than try to go back and revisit
the reasons
I do soon modify the 28a situation
yeah that's true
so I can draft something just based on
the discussion we've had and then we can
discuss that at a future work session
that'd be great thank you
does anybody else identify anything on
this list
just one quick thing the
um form that Mickey is talking about is
in the part of the bill that refers to
retroactive payments so obviously we'd
have to move that language into the
appropriate paragraph to preserve it
once we eliminate the retroactive part
of the bill
sits in section 6 Roman numeral six and
I think we would we can move it to
section for the you know form
yeah the the Retro I think is section
two of the bill starting on line 19.
I stand corrected so I think if you're a
structure section two we probably take
care of the Retro you win you're right
so again we'd heard for instance the doe
contract to recodify their laws we had
heard from uh director aliconis from OLS
about that as well as I think
representative Greg Hill I have not
heard any follow-up from anyone on this
as far as an amendment uh so perhaps
when we get the Department in we can see
where anything is with that I don't have
anything on that
um
the math learning communities program we
heard from ccsnh on that
um that's not in the governor's
recommended budget but you do have that
bill retained dual and concurrent
enrollment we had a separate bill that
is in here
1.25 million represents the difference
of what the governor funded versus what
that bill would have funded so that bill
was 3.25 million a year the governor did
2 million a year so that would be the
difference depending on how how much you
wanted to fund
two million years already in the
governor's budget yeah so if you if you
kept that alone it's at 2 million a year
now and then I think the courses go from
two to three or something like that it
increases the amount of courses
uh doe we had a house bill 542 relative
to a new data analyst position
that is not included in the governor's
recommended budget that position so that
would be incremental to the accounts
that you see in here
uh household 560 the contact
notification program administered by the
division of State Police we briefly
touched on that with the Department of
Safety last week that's only fifty
thousand dollars for them to to do that
work
and then the extraordinary needs
accountability plan depending on what we
do with Ed funding we'll make sure that
there's no unintended consequences there
if you move forward with the
extraordinary needs Grant
um as part of the plan then it's up if
you want to decide whether to change the
threshold for when an accountability
plan is required
but that's there's the same statute is
impacted in House Bill too so we'll
effectively get to House Bill 638 as
part of our house bill to work quick
question
that accountability plan is there any
place in legislation where it is defined
what exactly is an accountability plan
because
I'm trying to understand we've discussed
it as being a significant burden so you
know you you shouldn't require one for
schools to get fifty thousand or less
but if an accountability plan for a two
thousand dollar thing is something
scribbled on the back of a napkin and a
sign you know it would be a lesser
burden so I'm trying to see what the
complexity of the accountability plan is
and if there is a specific legal
definition or we're just assuming it
will be complicated
I think there is so if you open if you
have your house bill too yep uh on page
64 of your house bill too it's language
that's included in here but not edited
so if you go to page 64 and line 27
it kind of gives you some of the
criteria required for the uh
Grant plan
upon a quick review of that paragraph
it just specifies you know that you've
got to generate data and measure it and
report it back it doesn't say anything
about how complicated or simple it may
be
so you know I don't think it would be a
large burden unless there is a you know
rules making stuff where the Department
of Education may make that very
complicated just based on the statute it
seems that the requirement is pretty
basic that you know a small amount of
money you receive would require a small
amount of data to be provided because
you know how much time can I spend
talking about how I spend a thousand
dollars I I think these are good
questions and the department is planned
to discuss those with us because as part
of one of the subsequent requests that
they had was relative to Staffing to
administer and comply with those plans
so I think that's a discussion they'd be
ready to talk about thank you
AI sure can I just make sure I
understood you so
um just you know say line 57 the 16
million that's 16 million above what's
proposed in the
in the budget yes so there's the budget
of an x amount and all these are this is
what it costs with the additional uh
bills above what the government has okay
thanks just yeah I mean as as best of my
accuracy you know if anything you know
as we progress I'll make sure we are 100
accurate on everything but I'm I feel
confident in these but I make mistakes
so there could be something there
well the only one I I really felt
compelled to do something about was the
28-day violation
so if somebody has a
thoughts on any of the others
please come forward
Mary my only thought is I have lots of
thoughts but
um with regard to hb2 we don't have to
take everything that the governor put
into the budget and we can as we take
things out we can use those dollars for
a different purpose
so we have to take something out
somewhere yes I I just don't have the
dollars speaking can I I just address
that now I know that Ways and Means
brought us in I think was 130 million or
150.
yeah
um but I'm sure
if you define that 150 is that what
we're going to be short yeah
the 130 million dollars
their revenue estimate is lower than
what the governor's Revenue estimate was
I'm sorry I can give you any context but
there are also dollars that are Surplus
dollars there are other dollars that may
be available
how would we know that we have the
authority to use those
that question is probably a full
committee type of question
um as far as establishing full committee
um you know in the past when we've had
big cuts to do usually they'll split up
and give targets to each division and go
figure that out in this case uh even
with the revenue estimates being lower
there is like we've mentioned a lot of
surplus funds to close out 23 the rainy
day fund balance is is Big there's a big
unexpended education trust fund it's
really up to
I'd say the committee as a whole to
parse out how much money per division to
be able to do its its work
but we have 170 million dollars to work
with within the education Trust
we'll get to that it's not quite 170
anymore with it with the revenue because
that that number of Revenue is a lot of
that was education trust fund okay thank
you so but I have a a snapshot we can
walk through here shortly well let's
walk let's keep going
well real quick so all the bills we have
for tomorrow I've got some costs on
there so there's one that changes the uh
Grant amount for the charter schools
that's increased about five million
dollars a year uh the bills relative to
the EFA program so we have a bill that
changes eligibility we've got another
bill relative to the Department of
Education administering that program
rather than the scholarship organization
I don't have anything from the
Department on on either of those
um we have another bill relative to the
Department of Education being required
to provide their statutes and rules to
certain legislative committees with the
way that that was amended there's no
cost to that so you probably could if
you support that pass it there's no
fiscal impact any longer to that bill uh
521 representative you had mentioned
this was a bill that you're on so we'll
hear about that from the Department
tomorrow relative to episode of
treatment or no yes and uh the yeah the
um
quarter Replacements and then we do had
two we did have two education funding
related bills uh representative fellows
Bill relative to fiscal capacity
disparity Aid and additional Aid based
on free and reduced lunch as well as I
think representative Ladd relative to
enhanced special education as part of
the education funding formula so both of
those as you can see the price tag on
there those are rough estimates as
incremental total cost from what the
governor's plan was so that would be
above and beyond the funding levels of
the governor
we talked about the direct Medicaid
certification we'll talk more with that
with the Department tomorrow
there's the division of early learning
at the Department of Education I
sure
um that's my bill
um in my intent and I've spoken with
many people my intent on that bill is to
retain it and just retain it okay
and not to put it in the budget
we're not ready
and that rounds out the bills for
tomorrow and like I said there are three
on the house floor Thursday that if
passed probably should come to us so we
may get three more after this Thursday
they're all on the calendar without
recommendations so it'll depend on how
things go Thursday
the last two items on here uh in the
Department of Education had talked about
the in the um change to the snap
eligibility may impact the free and
reduced lunch population which was not
captured in the governor's funding
those grants will be paid out it's just
not accounted for essentially so their
recommendation was to carry some dollars
on the Surplus statement reflecting that
adequacy is probably going to be a
little bit more than we think because of
that new population that's going to be
that's already been approved by fiscal
that that's uh it's going to happen it's
just they don't have the data to make
the estimate but so that these are just
rough estimates as like a placeholder
and then lastly we heard from the
Department of Transportation
that they felt that the governors uh
recommended budget surplus statement the
lapse estimates may have been a little
too high so
um they had provided what they feel
could be an adjustment to those to
reduce the lapse estimate would
essentially cost you 20 million over the
biennium to do that
so that's that's essentially the entire
universe if you will of House Bill 2
House Bill one agency requests and all
your bills those last four pages
I know
the next uh page I'll I'll just just to
uh Mary's point
would it be
better
than we're trying to take action on
these is to retain them
I would say the ones that if if they are
ones you want to discuss as far as
budget affordability or including in the
budget certainly I'd say house bill 364.
House Bill 492 our
um our bills that don't carry a price
tag right and they pass policy and pass
the house already so now that we have
you know fiscal analysis on those you
probably could move those along if
you're okay with them and not have to
include them in the budget or retain
them you can just pass them separately
that raises a question if the money if
the money's taken out of them why are we
touching them
so bills are tagged for fiscal uh or for
finance committee early on and sometimes
they're amended and so in the case of
the second one the first one probably
shouldn't have been referred to us in
the first place but the second one uh it
was amended in such a way that it took
the fiscal impact away but on the house
floor it's referred to finance by the
time we do the fiscal analysis the
Bill's already here so so but those two
I I don't you wouldn't have to carry
anything in your budget plan relative to
those two bills
researcher because
what's the you know quickest way in
which we could uh you know act on those
bills because again I'm not sure what
the process is when can we you know
because again it's a policy bill with no
physical impact I don't think we should
really even
well we can we can vote a recommendation
anytime all right right so if we wanted
to recommend the two hat that don't have
any uh dollars in today
we can do that we technically today we
have a budget work session scheduled
tomorrow we have a work session on those
okay so tomorrow you could vote ought to
pass if you wanted to move those along
and then retain the others or uh
whatever you want to do with them
what's your bill
I have 620 and 601 and 601 I hope that
actually we could just stick that in hb2
I don't know if we can or not but it
would be nice if we could you certainly
can that one uh the department is asking
for a new position so if that was
something you were going to support
you'll hear from the Department tomorrow
and then it's up to you if you want to
support the bill and then also support
their request for a new position and
that's something we can talk through
with them tomorrow well anything we vote
for
on this list we've got to take something
else out over there so
well and I have if I may I have some
requests from um uh chair lad
um in terms of uh the overall education
budget and he was hoping to see an
increase in building Aid we've got 43
in each year of the biennium and he was
hoping that that would be increased can
you give a page number
actually I'm in the department of Ed
budget right now the one that gave us
it was that the
um the commissioner told us you know the
handy dandy that tells you all
everything it is Page 1205 if you wanted
to look in the big document
um and then tuition and transportation
it's 9 million and it's been 9 million
for as long as I can remember and the
actual cost is in excess of 11 million
for each year it would be a big Aid to
school districts if we could increase
that amount and CTE is a program that we
really have been trying to get more kids
into so a
cheerlead would like to see an increase
in that
and it's not 364.
so House Bill 364 doesn't change how
much money goes out it changes how the
reimbursement is calculated per per
District uh that plan that program is
bound by how much you put in the budget
so that that bill changes how the amount
is derived but it still stays within
nine million dollars so there's no
fiscal impact for that reason because
whatever you appropriate in the budget
is really what drives total State
spending for that program because it's a
it's not quite a proration but it the
the reimbursement rate is calculated
based on the state appropriation this
just changes a little bit of the policy
but behind the scenes if you will and
the uh for me and the other area I was
hoping to increase by 400 000 is adult
education when we ask the commissioner
um about that line
um he added that he would like to see
that 400 000 in addition to the amount
um that was originally requested
and the adult in people would like that
too
and that's all I've been rally for
Mary can you get more of that detail to
us so I can stick it in the budget here
I couldn't follow I couldn't find
everything you were talking about
it's
you have to do it now we can
so you've got some baby programs right
you got some more documents yes so
um so along the lines of Representative
Heath's uh topic she just brought up if
there are anything if there is anything
outside of what we've gone through here
that any of the members would like an
amendment for I'd like to add some money
to this or remove money for that you can
work with me I can add something to this
as a member Amendment if you will and
then have a document that makes it clear
what you're looking to do that can be
provided to the committee and you can
make motions that way and make changes
so the next page is a landscape oriented
this one it's just another uh summary
page of the decisions that you make in
house bill one and House Bill 2 that
have dollar impacts so at this point
we've really only done the law
enforcement accreditation program for
police standards and then a couple
Corrections and I'll carry every change
we make on here just so you can see your
net total by source of funds as we go
along
and then the next three this is in this
is in uh
this is actually 150 000. this is real
dollars So yeah so when you're looking
at that it's 150 000 yeah this isn't
right no this one's not right
no
see in in Department of Safety actually
saved us three thousand and seven
dollars with one of their requests so
every little bit helps you made some
money there for the general fund
so the the last three pages in this
packet are snapshots or Surplus
statements whatever you want to call
them for the education trust fund the
highway fund and then the fish and game
fund uh I have Incorporated house Ways
and Means revenues into these so if you
recall
uh it's still in the binder clip
document
look it looks like this
yeah so the education trust fund at the
top yep so uh you will see if you
remember this document I provided last
week or week week before and from the
bottom right the ending balance at the
end of fiscal 25 was like 148 million
dollars incorporating the house Ways and
Means revenues now that balance is 63
million so so that a lot of the uh the
variance between the governor's Revenue
estimates and house Ways and Means fell
into the education trust fund the rest
being General funds now did this
oh
you see this is what our our ways and
means numbers yes this is essentially
where you're at now with your house ways
it means committee Revenue estimates so
the governor's uh reconfiguration of
property business profits taxes that's
still included in here so if you look at
lines 14 15 and 16 since that's in House
Bill 2 before you I'm including that
adjustment in here if you take those
sections out I would take those rows out
and you can see those net to about 73
million and 24 and then 74 million and
25 as a
Revenue decrease of the education trust
fund and then the general fund Surplus
statement would have an offsetting
increase of Revenue got it okay
so this is uh I won't go into Super
detail with all this
I'll just jump down to line 32. here is
where you'll start to see
some new programs that were not
historically part of the education trust
fund so court ordered placements State
Testing building lease aid for Charter
Schools
the department of education
education trust fund Administration I
think it's like a student data system is
most of that there's an accounting unit
in the budget and then the Career and
Technical education renovation money
which is normally uh
a capital budget so you'll see those
essentially
you don't see it in 23 because those
historically had historically been
covered through other funding sources
mainly General funds and the capital
budget for the CTE
so as you make changes in
this is where discussing with the other
divisions and the committee chair is is
important
63 million looks like oh we've got 63
million to spend it may may not be
they may not be looking at it the whole
committee may not be looking that that's
all division choose money to spend they
may be looking for some more offset of
General funds for instance so I would
just make sure that there's
communication across the other divisions
as far as how much is really available
here for decisions of this committee
yes
can I ask a question about the um
inclusion of um the technical
Center renovation
historically that's something that we've
never ever put in houseville one or two
um I don't know if we're setting a bad
precedent and
now do we know if if they in fact have
even passed a bond to be able to do this
or um
I I just don't know enough about this
I'm very uncomfortable doing this to be
honest and I think this is something we
could you know because again we're going
to have to have the Department of
Education in a talk House Bill too and
there's House Bill 2 changes in here
moving this program from the capital
budget to the operating budget so
talking about if the locals have
approved this project for instance or if
there's any other projects or that we'd
have to drill down with the agency on
that which we haven't done yet that we
didn't get into that when they were in
last week or the week yeah last week
because in all honesty I would prefer
we have many many projects on that
building Aid list and if we're going to
take 12 million this is 12 million
dollars out of the education trust I
would rather see it go to building aid
for our schools than
this is a capital budget item I think
and I I just think we're setting a bad
precedent if we do this now I think in
the future whenever the education trust
fund has excess funding everybody's
going to dump whatever it is that they
possibly can into the trust
that's my feelings and I hate to sound
like a broken record I'm so I like to
make this quick point this is where
communication with your policy
committees will be important uh to know
if there's room in the capital budget
for instance for this so if the idea is
to move this from House Bill one and two
to House Bill 25 Public Works and
highways would have to be part of that
conversation we couldn't just make that
decision to change House Bill 25 over
here
just a quick question uh trying to
understand you know this particular
project
it's um
Career and Technical education what
exactly is being renovated is it a uh
you know ccsnh facility or our various
City facilities in schools I don't
recall the exact details of that
particular project because it would
change the way it would have to be
bonded and decided right
yeah I I I'm not an expert on this I
know it's relative to one location the
Sugar River Valley Regional tech center
in Newport and under those circumstances
I would say that most likely we cannot
ask the community to you know Bond or
pay that's a state facility owned by a
state school and we would no I'm wrong
okay that's why I'm asking because I
don't know I would appreciate any
background
uh Mary you might know her Mickey you
would know this um Capital has its
procedures uh to go through in order to
do a project
would this potentially do an end run
around those procedures or were those
procedures automatically apply here I
mean this is a totally different this is
a very new program it's new to do this
and are we pulling the rug out from
under how Capital would have done this
and the guard rails that they have in
place
and that's a great point to perhaps
coordinate with your policy committee on
it I can tell you the house bill 2
language does strike references to the
capital process from that yeah yes so I
think the idea is to change this from a
capital perspective to a cash operating
budget program
because usually when the CTE centers are
doing any kind of a capital work they
have a list and they have a date by
which their project is going to come up
and so they go to the capital budget
they've already worked with their
Community because they've got they're
supposed to have gotten approval from
the local community so that's how it
usually works there's a queue that's put
in place for CTE centers so I don't know
how
I don't know how this got here
I don't either yeah and and uh and I
don't either so that's something we
would we would discuss with the
Department on the process how why the
governor proposed this method versus the
traditional method
we got a bunch of outdoor notes Here
so um
so that school building Aid
sounds like the same kind of thing to me
that's a capital
investment
that one has always been an operating
budget item yeah okay I mean back it
back
pre-2010 we used to pay
throughout the debt service along with
the municipalities through the duration
of their bonding on the project since
the law changed in 2013 this is when
we're front loading our Aid so we give
them 80 percent the first year and then
20 of the year it's completed right and
then we're done with that project so
it's it's uh it's more of a current cost
now for the state than a long long term
and you will see I broke out on here on
lines 25 and 26 the tail payments
which is the payments that we're making
on the previously approved projects and
then you can see the governor did
include 22.6 million and then 26.1
million for new school building Aid in
this biennium
and then the 75 million dollars down
below his intention is to have that be
earmarked essentially for next biennium
but all of that is subject to to what
you folks want to do on this committee
but with the amounts and the timing and
everything
so the where's the current 50 million
so the 50 is essentially the line 25
plus 26 plus The Debt Service on the
bonding that we have in the treasury's
budget that's not in the education trust
fund that's a uh okay yeah so that's how
you get to the 50.
all right
that's the education trust fund snapshot
as we are today so essentially your
starting point with your budget starting
point where that was Bill 2 but with
your house Ways and Means revenues
Incorporated now
so similarly on the next page uh the
highway fund is built so you can see
um and I did this I will say rather
quickly today just to kind of see where
we're at
um working off the governor's document
changing it for the house Ways and Means
revenues which was a couple million
dollars more actually in uh fiscal 23
than what the governor had however since
the governor's budget came out the
department did come to fiscal committee
for some winter maintenance money from
Surplus so that netted out some of that
so uh long story short
you've got about 13.2 million and we
usually do the highway fund and Fish and
Game fund on a gap basis and so you'll
see that that assumes their end-of-year
Gap adjustment to make sure it still
balances on a cruel basis
we have received a few requests from
safety and D.O.T uh relative to Highway
fund uses uh
you don't have to pay for with Highway
funds for instance if you have General
funds available we can work out swaps of
funding or transfer from the general to
Highway fund which has been done for
many budgets in a row now whatever you
decide to do as far as the prioritized
needs from the Departments of
transportation and safety
we can figure out how you want to do
that mechanically in the budget
um
do we have any visibility and I know
it's purely guesswork and speculation
when would uh we start wouldn't win with
the legislature address the you know
funding imbalance in the current Highway
fund because pretty much right now we
are looking to spend it down in the next
biennium and have a spare change left in
it
and obviously as a long-term policy this
is not uh
tenable but if there is incoming reform
that would start addressing this I would
feel a bit more comfortable spending it
down to that level if I don't have the
confidence that that is happening you
know I would be much more cautious about
spending this because we're basically
gonna you know we are projecting running
or essentially out
the reserves well two terms ago there
was a bill
that Norm put forward
that changed registration fees
and what it did was it took cars that
didn't
use gasoline
and that they had the highest additional
fee
then he had a had it by miles per gallon
rating from the manufacturer
that High I mean cars to get 40 miles a
gallon they pay a little more or but
less than the no gas but a little a
little bit more than everybody else
and it marched down the gas mileage
until you got down up to like 15 miles a
gallon you paid the same things you're
paying now
because you're using a lot of gas so uh
it was a very spirited debate as I
recall and the issue became that you're
punishing people that buy electric cars
that's kind of what it came down to
and that I mean that wasn't the intent
the intent was to get
road tolls
from everybody more equally that that
was free huh use your fee would you use
it more you pay them right well that was
but I I think in in rsas they're called
Road toks uh instead of gas tax but I
think that was a good idea then I think
it's a good idea now but we don't have
it built actively on it but we do have
to do something because this this is
going to go to zero
and he said it
yeah there was also the proposal
um
of when you register your car you
register the amount of miles that you've
driven during that year so the more
miles you drive the more Road usage
you've used up and so having some kind
of a scale reflecting of how much you
actually use the road as opposed to how
much gas you use or you don't use and I
don't think we've ever come to a point
where we all agree which direction and
which to go yeah I think that I think
the argument on that one
uh had to do with people drive out of
state
you know thirty percent of the workforce
goes into Massachusetts and don't use
our roads at all so you know there was
everything
laughs
so just so you'll know there has been
attempted uh
you know and and the other one is is
just straight let's raise the road toll
and then and and most of one party says
no no no no no no no taxes so I mean
we're going to raise the toll for out of
state remember
but you know what
can we do that in hb2
50 cents
the tolls
oh tolls I thought I'm talking about the
gas tax oh can't do that no it's called
but it's called road toll in in statute
technically you can do it all it's all
stat story so what we heard from the
Department of Transportation under
current law the executive Council
approves the Turnpike tolls which is not
what we're talking about here with the
highway fund that's the turnpike fund
which we haven't heard anything about
that the road toll and motor vehicle
fees that's all set in statute and that
is
subject to any Amendment or any bill
it's just that I think we all agree at
least in this room that right now there
is a significant imbalance between you
know various fees paid by various
drivers who use roads equally and I
thought the original goal of having a
gas tax assuming everybody buys gas is
to make it reasonably fair for everybody
to pay their equal share and even then
you could argue some people buy gas in
New Hampshire to drive to mass but it
evens out with people who drive by gas
in Mass to drive to New Hampshire or
whatnot
but this is clearly going into a very
different direction because of all the
different fuels that we use these days
so you know I mean honestly one way or
the other will have to figure this out
because uh right now it's unfair and
it's getting even further down the path
of unfairness to various people so
anyway
so
you're right to notice that
deficit each year you know the current
year and that's nothing new that's been
the highway fund story for a decade and
a half at least and there's usually been
we've heard from the Department one time
fixes to get through and uh the get
through this year I would say is their
beginning balance that they're coming
into this biennium with that's how this
is working if you look at you know
you're starting with over 147 million
dollars
you know to begin fiscal 23
and that's essentially what's balancing
your budget for the next couple years
and as far as I I don't remember all of
them off top of my head I can only think
of I know there's a Senate bill
that implements a surcharge on electric
or hybrid vehicles like a hundred
dollars added which I think it was like
a million bucks a year or less than that
in new Revenue that's the only Bill I
can think of right now but there may be
others
so that's where we are with the highway
fund
um any if there's no questions on that I
just have one more page here
and it's the fish and game fund and I
presented this one slightly different I
presented the governors versus where you
are with division two right now I did
change the uh revenues to be house Ways
and Means revenues which the only change
is on row six and fiscal 23 you'll see
500 000
dollars difference there
that's the uh that's the only difference
that was made I will point out what I
believe to be a mistake in the
governor's
Surplus statement if you look at that
row five transfers from general fund in
fiscal 24 there's one million dollars in
in fiscal 25 there's one and a half
million dollars
there's actually not a general fund
transfer into the fish and game fund
there's general fund support in the fish
and game budget but it's not really a
general fund addition to the Fish and
Game fund so where we saw the governor's
final uh budget our final Surplus
balance of about seven million dollars
kind of on the bottom right there for
fiscal 25 based on making that
correction I think the fish and game
funds somewhere around 4.6 million of an
ending balance right now based on the
budget before you
clarification
so just to make sure I understand it
correctly the same amount of money you
know is supposed to be spent or you know
the revenue provided it's just that you
are saying that the governor's budget
seems to incorrectly state that this is
going into the fund when in reality it's
just operational funds that are provided
and used so nothing will come in here
okay but they only made the error on
this side
so basically the fact that we end up
with
2.5 million less in this fund does it
also indicate that we have 2.5 millions
of lapsing funds in the general budget
or was it just a one-sided error just
one-sided the general fund Surplus
statement captured that two and a half
million dollars already got captured the
second time she had to by mistake
correct that's what I needed to
understand thank you
ask about fishing game so fishing game
they wanted two more um
people that go out to do search and
rescue
and that would be from the general fund
so I did get clarification on that this
budget includes all the positions funded
what their request is is to change the
funding of two positions from Fish and
Game to General funds
so essentially to alleviate the use of
Fish and Game funds and have more
general fund support for their
enforcement but they've got the
positions authorized and funded already
in here they just want to change the
source of funds for those two positions
so
that's a switch from what we normally do
usually they support themselves
there has been that's where the general
fund infusion is so the one in one and a
half million of General funds is in
their enforcement unit
so this would be building upon previous
policies just to a more to have more
positions general fund than current and
then they want one other person that's a
secretarial in nature and that one would
be true correct and then we also had
heard that one of their arpa programs
that supports a couple of positions only
runs the first 18 months of the year and
it the numbers I got from them today
it's about 190 000 I think they told us
like 140. it's about 190 000 of general
fund support they would ask that they
could complete those positions for the
for the biennium and all of those are
presented on on this document here so we
would we want to probably do that or do
you think they have enough Surplus
themselves to cover all that
I don't know if I can answer that
question I think I think they would say
you could look at their balance and say
it could absorb it and then you look at
their operating certain deficit each
year and it would some would say you're
just taking away from the fund balance
to start the next biennium so it's
really a decision of the committee left
block river right bucket
did you ever hear back from Charlie I
did that's a great segue
so I have
is this relative to wait where's Charlie
Charlie McIntyre the one point yes three
million
Lottery
finally we can take action oh my gosh
don't know how to act
so Lottery had talked about adding uh
1.2 million approximately to fiscal 24.
to do a some software acquisition that
they wanted to implement so they gave us
a little bit of a write up here I can
tell you that division one did approve
the doit end of this transaction and you
can see in the memo here Lottery
Commission is not expecting this will
not change their revenue estimate they
had this part of their 158 million
dollar Revenue estimate in fiscal 24. so
this would be in the budget as other
funds Lottery funds but it wouldn't
impact your education trust fund
situation
so yep
um I'd like to move that um we um accept
and approve the proposal submitted To Us
by um the lottery
second and also their budget
yeah you could you could finalize their
budget close them out tentatively
everything's tentative of course and
they don't have any House Bill 2
sections so okay
I'll second
you did okay I already did you're my
manager I try
they submitted
which is
yeah but we're just authorizing them to
spend that money well and appropriating
and approve their budget right yeah as
submitted estimated everything they
spent had to be appropriate
no they're an Enterprise fund that's
right
well so the motion is to appropriate
that amount you know for the lottery we
don't have to appropriate to approve
they're an Enterprise fund they fund
themselves they have their own money
technically speaking will increase their
class 27 in fiscal 24 in their budget
here by this amount and that that'll be
the change that you see in the budget
document
and class 27 is transfers to the
Department of Information Technology
so all those in favor
we got something done
on this document here that was item
number 47 so when I do republish this
for another time I'll have some shade on
there so you'll see some progress on on
this list sorry
what else you got for us today mate
I I don't really have anything for you
that's not General Highway or education
trust fund and I'm not sure if if you're
feeling like you want to do much at this
point with that uh I the fishing game
position you probably could do that one
the uh the accounting Tech position
that's a fish and game fund position
it's one that the department had
requested and you know they're the
keepers of their funds so they must feel
that that's a prudent use of of dollars
so if you look on this uh busy schedule
here it's line number
uh 32
so this would be creating a new position
it's one that they had testified that I
think Mr chair was the day you weren't
here for fishing game so this was a
position they had testified that they
had had and then when admin Services did
the shared services program they lost
that position and then shared services
was somewhat wound back and they never
got the position back so they're looking
for for this uh essentially one that
they historically had had on staff
I'll move for that
seconded by Petrie
okay
and and the motion is for the um
Fish and Game new accounting technician
positions the amounts specified in line
32 of this summary which I'll write them
down and it's again to
appropriate or approve it approve it
approve the position yeah they already
have their money
yeah
okay
all in favor
all right
okay unanimous
they're in house bill one but funded
with Fish and Game funds and they they
would like you to reduce the fish and
game funds and replace it with General
funds and that's that Offset you see on
lines 33 and 34.
so that would essentially be a 350 000
general fund cost to do that
change
hold off on that one
and fish and game's other item uh just
above on lines 29 and 30. so this is you
can see all the federal funds
on lines 20 online 29 but that only runs
the first 18 months of the biennium and
then the 193 would carry out January
through June of fiscal 25 so uh
if you were to support
that general fund continuation of those
positions we could budget the federal
funds to that way that account would be
built for them for the two years but I
had a question I don't remember
um
if we fill in that six month Gap or
whatever you know the Gap is what
happens in the next year after that do
these positions go away because this is
arpa money isn't it
so where do those two positions go so
the arpa money goes away December so
what happens to these two positions
you're authorizing them and continuing
them with General funds so they would
say until the end of the biennium just
like any other position in the Bible so
there presumably they'll come back in
the next biennium for the full amount
for these two positions if they were to
continue those positions for the uses
yes
now with that exchange I'm understanding
it's not in the general fund yet
well
I'd rather wait and see what we got to
do
I'm not in the mood to spend money right
now because I think we've got to cut
somewhere
they always have funds fishing game is
pretty healthy
yeah but they want General funds to pay
for these positions wait
they had testified that they didn't feel
like what the work of these positions is
representative of what the hunters and
fishermen are paying licenses for so
that's why they were seeking General
funds versus using their license Revenue
to support those positions
that's up to so do we know what this
program's about
they they're told I don't want to
misspeak yeah but they said yeah the way
the way I understood it like like uh the
moss in the aquarium they have to uh go
in and force
enforce some of these things to make
sure that uh and they deal with
agriculture I believe it was and they in
other words they look in to see if well
there might be zebra muscle uh it's
environmental yeah and so they you know
it's not really a fish and game I mean
you're dealing with other areas and
that's what happens things get dumped
off the fishing game which really an
official game
one of the concerns I've had looking at
the fishing games just over the past
several years is that they had a really
healthy fun their expenditures are
pretty much flat and their revenues are
pretty much flat and they keep dipping
into about you know the tuna four or
five million dollars every year to
balance themselves out and it's like
three years in a row that they've had to
pull out five million dollars so on the
one hand I I feel torn because you know
on the one hand Fish and Game by and
large is healthy and they still have a
surplus but clearly that Surplus is
being
um drawn down because they don't meet
all their expenditures so there's a part
of me that says we haven't given Fish
and Game anything and
several terms maybe it's time to do
something for them even though they
still have a surplus but they've drawn
they've gone from 13 million surplus
down to I think five or three so I'm I'm
really torn one way or the other
well right I think uh what was it a
couple terms ago that we supplemented
with uh what's about 675
000.
this is this is four or five budgets in
a row that we've had some sort of
general fund support for the fish and
game fund yeah but I remember you know
it was it was a few hundred thousand
dollars now they're two and a half
million over the biennium of general
fund support
just when he spoke about the search and
rescue though I was flabbergasted at the
extent to which the number of rescues
are going on and the work that they're
doing
um
I brought up the question about
techman's Ravine that they had to go up
and help somebody up there and then he
proceeded to tell us about the numerous
um the two people they had to go up and
take chip out of the ice the two people
who died
um so you know I don't know if if we do
need to support them a little bit I I
struggled after their presentation I
kind of was blown away by the extent of
their work that I just never thought
that it was that extensive actually
just a quick remark to follow up on this
their funds should pay for what it's
statutory you know supposed to pay for
the more we expand their mission to go
above and beyond what that fund is
supposed to pay for we either have to
pay from the general fund or ask the
legislature to start adjusting what
those you know fees can be used on and
frankly I don't think I could support
charging Hunter for fees then go to
totally non-hunting purposes because
they shouldn't pay for all the other
stuff which leaves us to filling in the
money from the general fund and so I
don't really have a problem doing that
because we are asking them to go outside
of what we originally meant those funds
to be and if we give them the
responsibility we got to give them the
funding so
the question is I don't know that the
legislature gave me a responsibility
I think it's just kind of over over time
there's been an evolution of who goes on
rescues and things you know it's
did they involve themselves in this
process and now oh my gosh I don't have
enough manpower
well I
I will say with the search and rescue
they do have some dedicated funds for
that that they charge direct costs to
the search and rescue fund uh I don't I
think I'm circling back to this one
position I'm not sure if search and
rescue ties right back to that
um but didn't they start building for uh
they do have authority to to charge for
I think in negligent situations to try
to recover some of the costs of of the
rescued parties I don't think it's huge
dollars but they do get and they get
donations they also have a you can buy a
pass or yeah the hike safe card that
Revenue goes plus a portion of certain
other licenses registrations go to the
fishing at the search and rescue fund
too for a while it was
in a deficit situation but I think now
it's uh it's in positives which is good
um
but yeah as far as as far as this one
position this is a it was arpa funds
that that was the Genesis of of this
program and in those positions it's an
arpa money that only runs through
December of 2024 so that's where it's
they said they'd like to continue it
they don't feel it's a proper fish and
game fun use so that's why they're
seeking the general funds for the six
months for the six months
yeah and you know just looking I guess
the total expenditures if I get it right
I mean the past they got under 700 000
for the general fund I mean that's not a
lot when they're the whole budget is you
know 35 million they have a lot of other
funds which you know is to their credit
I don't think that necessarily means we
shouldn't fund them because they have
other funds
um The Fish and Game funds are
significant
um so as I said you know I'm torn on the
one hand that they're self-sufficient
but on the other hand do we withhold
money because they're self-sufficient or
do we provide a little bit of funding
for all the other things that they do
for the entire State
um I'm you know I think this is
something more to talk about because I
do not know which way I would go right
now
I said I need to get guidance on what
our division's got to do I haven't got
that yet so I'll talk to Ken with the
amounts here I think you could hold and
then figure it out later especially you
know the general funds may be uh at a
premium for you to with all this other
uh requests you've got from the other
agencies so I think having a
a more big picture to find might be make
it easier for you to know if you can do
these smaller
because right now my feet are planted
squarely in midair
and the thing is they all make sense I
mean that's not
that's uh
where are we
so I've got uh just to look at this the
schedule that you patched out and every
everybody got a copy of this I don't if
you want to give me a minute I can run
down and make copies of this yeah okay
it says division budget deadline 23rd
honestly
I wouldn't want to work backwards
because I'm sure there will be surprises
so I would want to just work as
aggressively as we can on everything
that we can do as early as possible and
let us be in that fortunate situation
that we are done two days early
uh that's what I'm saying I'd I'd favor
a very aggressive schedule as hard as we
can because I'm really worried as a
first-timer that I'm looking at the
to-do list and I don't know how we're
gonna get it done so how much runway
we've got to get to get this plane right
here I I you know I I'd be very
aggressive scheduling wise
yeah
it's a small one but it's I will have a
hard time supporting the Civics textbook
because I trust our communities to or
our schools to develop their own Civics
books but you do huh
so you would support the two million to
develop a Sex book yeah it says I would
have a hard time with that
specific Civics
yeah I don't see us going developing
curriculum that's not our role that's
outside our Lane
I don't know
excuse me
quick question sure
Mickey if I could point you to the
second third page of your handout the
house finance division to increase its
decreases to consider on your first page
of that line
um
education school security
it allocates 5 million as each but then
it also has a node there that it says
it's convert temporary position to
permanent to me that looks like straight
up funding to the public school
infrastructure fund does that just
happen to also include a position being
converted that way with a very bulk of
the money being for the actual fund and
the little amount for the position yes
I've got the detail behind that request
it's 4.9 million in changes got it for
the program and then some for the
position and administration just wanted
to clarify thank you
foreign
sorry I always forget about that um that
commission we support
um safety
construction or not Construction
safety initiatives in public non-public
Charter Schools we have a list of I
think there were over 350
um
schools that have been impacted by these
dollars so these are for safety for
schools to implement safety factors oh I
got I'm familiar with that I mean I've
been on the school board in Windham
we've done certain of those projects I
just you know the description in that
line was a bit unclear and I wanted to
make sure I understood it correctly and
thank you it's a very Hefty process they
go through Amy from the Department of Ed
is is excellent
okay
so as far as the schedule goes yeah uh
the
23rd division budget deadline is really
the day we ask
our office really asks for the divisions
to finish their decisions because that
gives us essentially one work day and
that weekend to turn everything around
for that Monday which is likely be the
day that we present
the divisions will present their work to
the full committee
and then
the 27th 28th and 29th possibly would be
when the full committee will exec not
only house bill one and two but the 51
other bills that we have I'm assuming
unless unless they schedule another
exact session in between but all of the
bills that we're retaining we have to go
through the motions and do a full
committee vote to actually retain
and that's that's customary that's
normal
last
term didn't we do the retained bills
afterwards
so all the bills have to be reported by
that day which is
the 30th but we can report retain we
report retain thank you yeah and then we
have the whole summer and have to do a
final retained Bill report by whatever
the day is October November which is
ought to pass itl Amendment whatever and
then that'll be the first session of
January to take those up the house
so you can see on here we're gonna we'll
lose the ninth we have a session this
week
and we'll lose the 23rd but again that's
our deadline day anyway so I don't and I
will say some of you have maybe done
this before I'm not sure we haven't we
definitely didn't do it two years ago
because we were remote we've actually
had situations and I yeah I hope I don't
bring this up where we where you've been
in Committee in the state house and then
you run up for a roll call to vote and
then like that's happened before
um it's not an ideal situation but
sometimes it's just the nature of the
scheduling and the volume of work so I'm
looking at that week of the 21st 22nd
23rd is you may be in session and we
might be
meeting at the same time if we don't if
we don't have everything done by then
I remember that so it's trying to get up
the stairs when they yell yeah
divisions
we we well I I we can meet we haven't
noticed yet but we can it's still within
time that we can notice Friday uh we
also already have in the books a work
session
for I should have actually included it
on here so we've got a budget work
session
I'm sorry Bill's Work session tomorrow
at 10 but I also booked at one o'clock a
budget work session so if we get done
the bills and you want to use that time
for anything tomorrow it is noticed so
we could meet tomorrow after all those
bills
if we were going to do that
what would what would the topics be and
that and that's up to the committee we
also have Wednesday scheduled at 10
o'clock as all day essentially wide open
uh my my goal today was to kind of throw
everything out there and then maybe as a
group we can decide who we want to hear
from because we know we
definitely any of the Department of
Education in uh you're definitely going
to want Department of Safety and
transportation I would think to at least
go through the house bill two sections
and in a little bit more detail
um but as far as even within those maybe
education is the bigger one like what
specifically do you want just so we have
the right people here
quick question yeah
um I uh you know
a couple of us were able to uh you know
take advantage of an invitation from UNH
to look over the facilities of the
whitemore center and whatnot and as part
of the discussions during that visit
their athletic director and other people
involved were asking whether you know it
would be useful for them to explain the
need to the committee or if it would not
be a good use of time I just wanted to
bring that up now while we are still
thinking about planning I don't know
whether we'd feel the need for that or
not obviously you know I cannot you know
two of us in this room have been there
so you know we can say what we've seen
but I you know whichever way this
committee would like to go about it they
are available for that but I told them I
cannot say that it would be great to
come here because our schedule is brutal
and I don't know whether it's time well
spent or not right I support I can't
believe I'm saying this but I support
the hockey Rick
um and I do so
um I've heard from a number of people
who are I highly respect about it's not
just the hockey rink they're trying to
make this an Enterprise facility
so that by putting the money into it
they can
bring in thousands of people for various
different
um entertainment venues or
um they can offer it up as as for rent
for
um school teams and a lot of different
reasons so I was really impressed with
some of the testimony that I heard
through my computer
um so I shocking myself to say that I
support this actually even though I
kidded the governor should be about
football
hmm so that was in the governor's budget
basically when I really feel strongly
that we need to bring the University
Systems budget up to 100 billion dollars
I think you know that's what it was back
in 2011 and it was cut drastically
um in uh shortly I can't remember
exactly the was it 2011 it was cut
yes and it was they were just decimated
and if we could get them back up to the
100 million I think that would be a good
thing I think they're already at 99 so
wouldn't even take very much money to
get them there
yeah maybe I can add
um and this is obviously not the entire
amount that they're going to need in
order to build the structure
um but it's a huge boost for them in
raising the private funds and to have a
partnership public-private partnership
to get the rest of the money to have
this in there so it's I think is it 30
million was that what it was around it's
over 30 and about they'll have slightly
over 10 from the University funds eight
from the general fund and the rest race
through uh you know from private funds
and it's not even just the ring itself
actually that's probably going to be the
least affected part it's really the
infrastructure part of the building the
local rooms their facilities right now
are
very very old and you know 25 years in
sports a lot of things changed in just
the needs for what it takes and uh you
know I'll bring the materials they gave
us and you know explain if the committee
would like but I just didn't I wanted to
bring this up also to make sure that if
we schedule things if the committee
feels that it would be valuable to hear
from them you know they are more than
willing but I you know I'm fine I
I'm good yeah so that will simplify
things
I have to say I'm
I'm a little lost between the governor's
budget blazing means forecast
and then what's in here and what's not
in here so it's like uh
never happened I gotta be doubled
and possibly by
I mean tomorrow I think we have a pretty
big workload I mean we've been going
through bills pretty quickly retained
but I think the ones tomorrow could have
a lot of discussion and we may have
a lot of folks coming in is my guess and
it's up to you Mr chair and the
committee who you want to hear from it's
not a public hearing of course but it's
whoever the committee wants to hear from
to do its work
um we may have time on the back end I
scheduled that just as a just in case
but uh if not Wednesday I think we could
probably fill a couple hours with the
doe again so just jumping back to this
busy sheet here they had provided after
their uh presentation to us
so they had only brought forward the
school security the five million dollars
a year as part of their uh plan then
they had the accountability plans
administrator they've noticed a couple
hundred thousand dollars worth of
position funding errors in their budget
and then they're also seeking
consideration for enhancing some
positions that are vacant now to fund
them at levels they think are necessary
to hire so we haven't really heard from
the Department on those requests as well
as a lot of the House Bill 2 sections
that they didn't get to so perhaps we we
could
bring the doe if they're available back
in Monday uh Wednesday I'm sorry to go
through those requests and the house
bill two sections that works okay we're
going to have a lot of Education
tomorrow they're all education bills and
then I'll check their availability for
for Wednesday to go over all those okay
because we have positions in hb2 that we
don't even know if the department wants
and uh the other position too the bill
we retained the data analyst position I
think I don't think we did that with
them here when we retained that bill so
we could talk about that position as
well
I think that was house bill
oh
542 one of our retain bills so when
they're talking about their position
changes and the uh accountability plan
position we can talk about that data
analyst position as well
I don't know if that'll fill an entire
day or if it'll just be the morning it's
hard to predict how much will get done
at any given time
um so I'd hate to leave a whole
afternoon wide open so we could maybe
trying to think of what we could do that
afternoon maybe I'll come up with some
by tomorrow but right now they're
generic work section sessions on purpose
so we can be flexible I know some
committees will say you know make it
very clear what they're doing that time
which is nice but having a generic work
session for the on the budget gives you
flexibility to
do what we need to do whatever day
any work session you can you can make
your tentative votes your
recommendations doesn't have to be
posted as anything else we've been
voting right now I mean yeah any any of
these meetings that we're at or
open for votes
true
yeah oh it has to be agreed to book
oh I know I mean if if we're gonna have
votes and you won't have substitutes
so what are you envisioning tomorrow
Tuesday afternoon is that can doe stick
around for that afternoon or what will
we be what's your plans in the morning
huh what we didn't finish in the morning
if we do yeah I'm fairly certain we'll
run into the afternoon to take a break
and come back in the afternoon those
bills are not they're all scheduled at
10 so we can take them in order we can
break as needed just recess until a
certain time and come back and finish
where we left off a few in particular I
just think May
may go on a little bit
529 I think is um a bill that will maybe
want to ponder on a little bit
um and representative Ladd and um
representative luno will probably talk
to that and we looking at what the
governor's formula is in addition to
some of the elements of 529 we may come
up with a very nice formula
for consideration
um it's a school funding bill it's um if
you recall in the last session we had it
it's got disparity in it and um the
additional free and reduced lunch Aid
and hands-free reduced lunch hey so this
was what was in place
in 20
20 and 21 maybe I can't remember
this was when actually Senator Khan and
and representative Luna worked on Ed
funding back in that biennium yeah yeah
and then so the first four bills that
day could go quick then we've got two
EFA bills and then a charter school bill
two Ed funding bills and then the
Medicaid direct certification bill so
those are those are pretty significant
issues you may get a lot of uh testimony
I'm assuming representative Ladd and
perhaps representative Luna will be here
like they were with the other education
bills so
I think we'll get a lot tomorrow
the 601
601 I I believe the nutrition people
will be here I think I told them when
they called me that we were of a single
mind in division two that we supported
the Medicaid direct certification
I hope I wasn't out of line doing that
but it seemed that we were all really
for it
um I don't know if that there's another
I mean as of now
as far as I'm concerned I think it would
be a good idea to consider replacing the
fnr with numbers based on that does not
mean I support that bill has passed
which would increase which would include
actually
participating in the direct
certification so as far as we are
talking about the school funding formula
itself yes other policy parts of that
bill not so much just to make sure we
are on the same page okay just to let
you know too that it will not even be
possible for us to
um apply because the it's the
program pilot is not open fully
understood
but we could we could
we could all if I may
if we could authorize it authorized to
join the program if it comes available I
mean we could we could put language in
uh and exactly that's when I spoke with
um the folks from the Department if we
have that authorization in place then
they can go forward when in fact it
becomes available
so they have because right now from what
I understand we've never given that
authorization to the commissioner I was
of another mind I thought he had that
authorization but we never gave it to
him as far as I know so um by doing that
I think that puts that in place and they
just gets it out of the way they have
that power if they want it my
understanding it's using the statistics
for Medicaid not the actual names
so never
yeah I mean it was not a data link for
individuals it was just using the stats
of the uh from Medicaid okay yeah
because you could do it by ZIP code ZIP
code
the way we discuss using it in the
education formula would still basically
just be statistics aggregated no
individual information whatsoever again
actual direct certification totally
different ball of wax but as far as
school funding is concerned using those
numbers would not have any privacy
concerns or anything
but that would also resolve the problem
not getting the parents to submit the
forms
it's complicated
as a former Title One director
getting parents to fill out those forms
is near to impossible for my city of
Manchester for example we have a certain
number of students that um do apply but
I'd say it's at least three times more
Manchester has actually Manchester asked
that we submit this bill because for
them it will save them so much time and
they will have actual accurate numbers
that they've never had before for that
reason because they don't fill out the
forms
right and and just collecting the forms
and and putting the data together at the
school you know an administrator and
then you've got to certify a certain I
think it's three percent and then so you
have to chase those parents and if they
don't give you the data then those kids
are off of uh free and reduced lunch
which is you know that's and that takes
a lot it's a lot of administration time
just a quick note that I've heard
sorry reasonable objections to the
automatic enrollment that people who
qualified for Medicaid into the free and
reduce lunch program that in a sense you
are
a lot of people choose not to enroll
because you know there is a stigma
because they want to protect their
privacy and so on and so forth I do
absolutely support you know looking into
using those numbers aggregated and so on
and so forth for the purpose of
replacing the fnr portion of the formula
with something that's more accurate but
I wouldn't necessarily even be
comfortable supporting the policy goal
of using the Medicaid data to enroll
kids directly into the free and you know
free reduced lunch I I just clarifying
again where I'm coming from so there are
concerns but if we are just looking at
the funding you know formula I think
that you know I'm very comfortable with
that beyond that it becomes complicated
to a no to you know if you take these
two arguments and you put them together
what you've got is a slush fund no no no
no no just listen
right now they're having trouble getting
parents to apply for it okay we're going
to solve that problem
statistically we're going to take the
Medicaid numbers and we'll say Okay 14
of your school district is qualified for
f r
so we pay him based on 14 percent
somebody's still got to apply for it to
get it
the student's still going to have to
bring a piece of paper in right so now
we've got 14 we're paying for and they
only get six percent right that register
for it because the school do they know
they don't I mean how do they know
somebody's on Medicaid
please if we were to do Medicaid direct
certification
Medicaid data
School data
would be
confidentially linked
so
this info would key into the school
identification right
using the i4c system
and then that would
give the school a list
a confidential list only to a person who
is authorized and has signed off saying
it is confidential information not to be
distributed or used by anybody there are
strict guidelines okay now let's keep
your scenario in place now let's carry
that into implementation and then the
children would be eligible for free and
reduced lunch would somebody has to tell
them
that would be the responsibility of the
school
okay now if we're talking about stigma
to say parents could refuse it
uh yeah because they already do that now
they do it with TANF and snap programs
yes they automatically automatically
it's a list and it it just comes down
and
if they they don't the parents don't
even have to make out a floor TANF and
snap are in the original agriculture
legislation
Medicaid hadn't come to be yet that's
why it didn't get into the legislation
that's why we have this outlier and
that's why the need Now 37 states are
already doing this
so over time I think we'll get to 50
states
but the the real
the important most important of all of
it is that more kids would get
a feeding program right which is good
and the second piece is that in terms of
the adequacy formula we would have more
accurate numbers to go from which is
good for our state it's good for school
districts it's good it's good all the
way around
so Mr just a quick note
my concern the way where I'm coming you
know when I'm talking about using the
Medicaid instead of the 300 use is that
if I understand correctly that portion
of the adequacy is meant to compensate
school districts you know because the
assumption is when they have more people
who live in poverty they are less likely
to be able to raise adequate funds to
provide education so in the intent for
the funds that are part of that other
Quest is not to pay for lunch itself but
to you know
give the school additional funding so
they can provide comparable education
even though their tax base may not be
able to correct me if I'm wrong but
based on that you know right now the
fact that all those kids in schools
during kovid did not have to file for
free and clear to just you know get free
food severely decrease the incentive of
any parent to fill that paperwork and
you know right now we are underfunding
schools who should get more money
because the number of students register
this below so the intent is to correct
that imbalance and just take the same
amount of money but allocate it
correctly you know so that you know
schools get it in the exact ratios that
they are you know or that they deserve
based on the number of people who meet
the statistically correct right at the
you know District level so in that sense
I think using those numbers in the
adequacy formula instead of the free and
reduced would be a significant step
forward because it's better quality data
it better measures
what we originally meant to measure
through free and reduced
those numbers yet not we're still going
to continue I believe the same way we
are right now we don't have to we're
using the statistical numbers not it's
not that's not well I mean that's that
would have to be
um
authorized we'd have to say we'd have to
give the risk Department about that
Authority right correct but hb2 I mean I
think we're I think we're all in
agreement there uh my my issue has to do
with the gap of if we're just going to
authorize it for a school district and
send them a check
what happens it's it's funding
how do I self-identify if I don't
self-identify now why am I going to
self-identify later
well the parents are not submitting the
forms they know they're eligible they're
not submitting the forms what's changing
because we use Medicaid data other than
more money going to the schools well
it's a reimbursement program so the kids
have to take the meals before they
reimbursement comes but um the
difference will be
Mickey help me if I have this wrong the
Medicaid numbers
will link with student data and so
schools will be notified of those people
that are eligible and those families
will be notified of their eligibility
without having to fill out a form
okay so we're basically taking over the
responsibility from the parents well
a lot of
educator there are many parents who are
number one those families that have
English as a second language have
difficulty doing that
um parents sometimes just never get to
it because they either don't care or
they don't want to or whatever for
whatever there are a million reasons and
some don't understand the paperwork
getting parents to fill out anything is
difficult
um so having to put down your
information parents are very reluctant
to do that and I understand why I mean
it's it's personal information and they
don't they don't know who's going to be
looking at those forms I get it
um so there are a myriad of reasons and
then the worst part of all is when
you're looking in the face of a hungry
kid and you know that they should be
eligible for from reduced lunch and
they're not
and so it well it's hard
when we had everybody eligible during
covet it was wonderful because everybody
ate I remember my daughter telling me at
Central High School they'd come in
they'd bring boxes and boxes of lunches
everybody ate nobody thought about free
and reduced nobody thought about
anything they just thought about I'm a
high school kid I'm hungry and I'm gonna
eat it was wonderful and and there was a
lot of conversation right now about how
well free the free lunch program went
and is there money at the federal level
to do that across the country so and
like you're shaking ahead right now
there's a lot of opposition to that I
don't see it as taking responsibility
away from parents as much as enabling an
easier path for the parents to achieve
something for their students that they
probably do want their kids to eat and
it's kind of like instead of me having
to keep track of my passport and when
I'm due I get a notification I get a
notification when my driver's license is
renewed and I can just push a button and
and get my so it's away it makes the
path easier doesn't take away the
responsibility as far as I'm concerned
but enables them to do it a little bit
easier and it's hard to there are
unfortunately there are barriers for
some parents to achieve some of this
some of it their own fault some of it
not their own faults so it's it makes
the path easier to make sure their kids
get fed we should get back to this
though because tomorrow we're going to
be having this conversation again
important to be sitting there if I may
would have just 15 seconds
the head shaking thing was indeed in
regards to the concept of fully free
lunches for everybody because trust me I
know how much
would waste results in situations like
that and also I don't think it's our
place to you know feed the kids from
families like mine who can very well
take care of the needs of the kids for
lunch we need to focus on you know the
need to feed the kids with families
cannot afford good food and I would not
be comfortable with expanding this to
everybody because of a lot of reasons
more than I would like to get into in
the 30 seconds I'm trying to stick to
but you know
we got to make sure every kid you know
has another option absolutely
okay well
the point of this is that we if we want
to do this it's
we're setting up a pattern so they can
apply for a prototype
okay
we're not spending any money yet
yeah there's some the department can
speak to that tomorrow the big impact
would be in fiscal 26 when you see the
result of the direct certification
impact the adequacy formula but that
won't affect the 24-25 biennium by the
time it goes into effect
it wouldn't be until outside this
upcoming biennium all right
anything else today folks
I I will point out that I think GNC
meets on Wednesday so I'll do my best to
see who is available to come see us but
some folks may be tied up with that
um
looking ahead so we do have Friday the
10th as a potential day is that a day
that it's fine with me if we could come
up with yeah I'll see I'll see who's
available that day
um
I'll see if we can get anyone in before
and then I think as long as we post it
by sometimes Wednesday we'll be good
um is town meeting in town meeting day a
day you still want to try to get
together whoever's available or
um
you're not going to be here I will be
out on March 14 years
I think we could do a half day okay I
think it's
I
couldn't vote because you brought me to
conquered perhaps sometime between now
and you know middle of this week when we
have to notice for next week we'll we'll
know about perhaps the public hearing
because I think I said I think we're
gonna lose a day at some point here to
do the house bill one and two public
Hearing in reps Hall I don't know when
that's going to be yet
but I assume it'll be sometime between
now and the 23rd
um
13th the 13th is probably about unless
again unless uh something full
committees scheduled that day like the
hearing that's what he's talking about
Wednesday oh right right yeah Wednesday
do you remember what time they said
okay I know that was yeah I'll double
check on that
okay
yeah I think yeah I think
I think we've got enough for this week
knowing that we've already got tomorrow
afternoon available and all day
Wednesday and then I can do the Friday
the 10th as well hopefully by then we'll
have some clarity on full committee
stuff that may interfere with what we
want to do and then once we fill those
in then we can work around that okay
so we'll have to check with chair Weiler
as far as dates for like I said the full
committee exec usually we do those bills
when we do House Bill one and two
usually we also do another executive
session to dispose of some of those
bills ahead of time which we haven't
done we don't have that scheduled and
we've got like 50 bills so that last
week I got to think 27 28 29 the
committee will have plenty of stuff to
do
um
so
24th is fiscal yeah
uh it could be one actually I think
that's I think I it usually is 10 but
the last couple have been one for some
reason
um
but but my hope is you're done by the
the day before that so hopefully this
doesn't impact that so hopefully fiscal
doesn't impact our work
um
so yeah that's where we are I think
we've got some days as long as we don't
have any crazy weather or any other
surprises
um
everything
again
literally every day other than March 14
I'm available until the end of June
okay so we'll
be back at it tomorrow morning
yes
oh did you see on the news uh Crestline
in California they had to fly people
they had to fight uh people out in
helicopters because they were uh oh
we're stranded stranded but that's so
much bull I can I could see the
Crestline my house
well I live in San Bernardino though in
Foothills well a woman in our church
grandson is snowed in the floor he was
that'd be fun it was eight eight to 12
year olds oh my oh that didn't drive you
nuts yeah yeah we're done for the day
thank you yeah that's big bear that's
actually they should have brought to ski